how surprised are you that Hugh Jackson
staying as the Cleveland Browns head
coach that just hit my my email inbox
from the NFL Network assignment desk
this is a this is a team release this is
no report the team sent this out
it's crazy man how do you how do you how
do you fire your grocery shopper and the
man in charge of all of this and then
announce that you're keeping the guy
who's one in 27 I mean and then I guess
you'll have to find a new grocery
shopper that's got to keep Hugh Jackson
for a year I mean it's just the absolute
wrong way to go about building a team
when you've got the opportunity you've
got the number one overall pick you've
got you've got a ton of draft picks it's
all set up
you know Sixers style I guess and and if
you want to have a general manager to
come in and he's gonna want his own
coach I mean yeah I honestly don't have
an answer for this one none zero but if
you look at the draft picks the problem
that I've had with the Cleveland Browns
is that they've had draft picks
they just haven't used those draft picks
wisely and I could understand changing
that have they seen enough in the
coaching abilities of Hugh Jackson even
though they've won one game here and may
not win a game is see once I mean as a
coach ever survive this this kind of
stretch in the NFL what a mess you have
to understand no no I can't imagine
somebody go I mean look the Giants just
fired a coach midseason for the first
time since 1976 because he started to
intent so but you have you know you have
to understand about how empty the
cupboard was and then who in that well I
guess we'll find out at some point when
someone writes a book about it who is
the one who really decided to raise
their hand and say Carson Wentz wasn't
top 20 talent this week who is the one
who decided yes let's accept that trade
offer from the Houston Texans instead of
taking to Shaun Watson who who's that
guy who are those gentlemen
and and if you Jackson is not that guy
and he's the guy who apparently left
carson wentz his pro day and called him
up and told him how much he loved him
that's all you hear about and so maybe
he doesn't have his fingerprints on that
maybe the guy just got bounced just did
I don't know bawd crazy all that said
the way you go Hugh attract talent in
the NFL in the front office
is you say to somebody okay you've been
waiting for a job like this here it is
you got all these draft choices you get
to choose the coach now someone's gonna
come in and say okay now you got to keep
you Jackson what if you don't want the
guy I mean but in its no offense to Hugh
anybody who's gonna want to leave you
want to get the you know you want to get
somebody who's been waiting in the front
office behind save Bill Belichick or
Ozzie Newsome to come in to Cleveland
and straighten it all out but you got to
keep Hugh Jackson they're really gonna
leave their job I can't imagine he's
Rich Eisen NFL Network and it's Atlanta
tonight the Saints in the Falcons now
you were going to fly to Atlanta but
because of the fires you were not able
to get out of office answers oh no no I
was able to get out but I mean you know
the fires were we're a little too close
to home literally figuratively
so in the network and NBC we're awesome
they're like to stay home you know you
know my setup Suzie and the three kids
and it's frightening there's just no
other way to put it it is frightening
the winds can blow anywhere and so I'm
glad to be home you know I will
definitely miss being at this huge game
but I'm glad to be home and in LA but
tonight is huge Dan I mean Atlanta
Atlanta needs to this is must-win
territory four games to go and I always
thought the NFC South was going to be
some sort of round-robin where everybody
picks each other off in week 17 and game
256 might might be you know Atlanta at
Saints on NBC but that last game works
in all all or nothing or a huge game
where it's a bye week or or a road trip
to start the playoffs but the Saints win
tonight they wrap it up pretty much they
would have a huge lead a three game lead
on Atlanta
Carolina takes on the Vikings this week
and they've already lost the season
series to New Orleans the Saints could
wrap it up tonight with a win and
personally I think they do I just love
their running game I love the way that
they're playing and I think they have
the the mettle to go on a short week on
the road and win in this building
what did ask you about the plays the
suspensions this week that you had drunk
and he had Smith Schuster but George
Iloka somehow talked to his way out of a
suspension I mentioned that this isn't
the targeting rule that College has but
it's the NFL's version of a targeting
rule they're just they have more time to
review this you have a 24 hour period
where you can say you know what on
second thought we're gonna suspend you
for a game as opposed to in college you
got 90 seconds to look at a review maybe
not all the angles and you could decide
a college football game by sending out a
marquee player for targeting do you
think the NFL with ten suspensions for
on the field play has a targeting rule
it's just not in you know not using that
name well they've had a targeting rule
forever it's called the fine system you
know Brandon Stokley tweeted about it
yesterday and he's a guy who's who's
gotten many many years of catching
footballs in the NFL he's just like the
reason that that's the deterrent is the
fine system and the reason why they have
targeting in college you can't find the
players my problem with targeting any
and in college is it is where replay is
used to judge intent sometimes yeah
which is dumb
it's crazy where you think you know its
intent and you don't know if its intent
let's go into the hood and let's check
out intent and then you go under the
hood and you see well a little piece of
the helmet caught a little part of his
facemask so that's it
the kids not out there now out for the
game and out for the next half of the
next game and it's so arbitrary between
the pac-12 and the Big Ten and the SEC
and it drives me insane
that that rule you know part of me
agrees with mike mitchell with his with
his soliloquy yesterday where he said he
got fine because because Andy Dalton
threw a bad ball oh yeah
where he threw it in a spot where
anybody who reads a defense knows the
defense that Mike Mitchell is playing
and no a quarterback should know not to
throw it in spot X because in spot X his
receivers going to get blown up
I remember the the weekend where this
all kind of changed in the NFL Dan if
you remember was I forget what season
was but it was when Eric LeGrand Eric
LeGrand got wound up getting carted off
and then eventually as we found out
paralyzed and hitting Rutgers into the
next day three three incidents hit
happened where Mohamed Massaquoi was
blown up by James Harrison Brandon
Meriweather went top rope in the middle
of the field against Todd Heap the tight
end of of Baltimore and DeSean Jackson
got absolutely obliterated coming across
the middle by Dante Robinson of the
Falcons and Marshall Faulk went on game
day morning the next week and said the
the play of Dante Robinson blown up
DeSean Jackson was on his quarterback
who I believe was Nick Foles and also on
on DeSean Jackson whom should have known
running through the middle of the field
what defense he was running into and he
kept running
Foles through behind him and Robinson
blew him up because that's the type of
defense that was being played and and
Jackson should have known he needed to
stop in the middle of the field
otherwise he's running into trouble so
these things need to be taken into
account sometimes that the players are
all instinctive to bring it I guess all
full circle is they are instinctively
making plays and targeting it does not
take that into account they think that
somebody's going to come across the
middle and say all might be called for
targeting so let me like the magic
bullet change my path in midair and try
and avoid the head and it just angers a
lot of people it's just not a perfect
system when it all comes down to it
there should be some form of uniform
suspension that if you are flagged for X
and you make contact with body part Y
with helmet that equals this suspension
and that's it and we've just fit it in a
box and everyone is a fan and a player
and a coach an announcer understands
what it is have fun tonight rich good to
catch up with you glad the family safe
but Rich Eisen NFL Network for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]